lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en la idea de una fracción
para acción
ahora como acabamos de aprender lo que
es una fracción vamos a pensar en ellas
como una parte de un entero aunque más
adelante vamos a pensar en ellas de más
formas ahora a qué me refiero yo con una
parte de un entero pues imaginémonos que
tenemos por aquí una pizza y vamos a
dibujarla con un color que se parezca al
de las pizzas o sea naranja estoy
tratando de hacerlo lo más circular
posible y digamos que dividimos la pizza
en cuatro pedazos iguales así es que
dividimos así y lo acabamos de dividir
en dos partes iguales y luego dividimos
así
y ahora sí ya lo divide en cuatro
rebanadas iguales a cuatro pedazos
iguales
que tomamos la pizza y la dividimos en
cuatro pedazos iguales pero digamos
también que en tres de estas rebanadas
tenemos queso únicamente que eso tenemos
únicamente queso y en esta última
rebanada también tenemos queso pero en
esta última rebanada no sólo vamos a
tener que eso también tenemos aceitunas
y ahora nos podemos preguntar qué
fracción de esta pizza tiene aceitunas
bueno pues esta pizza tiene cuatro
rebanadas exactamente iguales cuatro
partes iguales y sólo una de esas cuatro
partes iguales tiene aceitunas
y es que podemos decir que una de las
cuatro partes de esta pizza de la pizza
tiene aceitunas tiene aceitunas una
cuarta parte de la pizza tiene aceitunas
bueno pero seguramente también habrá
otras personas que digan oye pero
cuántas rebanadas de la pizza tienen
únicamente queso bueno pues esta parte
si tiene queso pero también tiene
aceitunas así es que a esta rebanada no
la vamos a contar pero aquí tenemos 123
rebanadas que únicamente tienen queso
tenemos tres rebanadas que sólo tienen
queso o sea que tres de las cuatro
rebanadas únicamente tienen queso tres
cuartas partes
de la pizza sólo tienen queso sólo
tienen que so ahora hagamos unos cuantos
ejemplos más porque esta idea de las
fracciones es una de las ideas más
importantes y más útiles que puedes
tener en tu cabeza así es que hagamos
otro par de ejemplos bueno aquí ya
tenemos una pizza rebanada pero ahora
mejor dibujemos no sé animalitos o bueno
mejor fruta digamos que tenemos una
naranja y aquí tenemos nuestra naranja y
aquí tenemos un plátano este es el mejor
plátano que he dibujado y un limón pero
de esos limones amarillos no de los
verdes y también tenemos una manzana
roja aquí está nuestra manzana
y finalmente vamos a dibujar una fruta
más vamos a dibujar unas uvas pero ahora
si yo te preguntará qué fracción de
estas frutas que tenemos dibujadas aquí
son amarillas bueno pues aquí podemos
decir que tenemos una dos tres cuatro
cinco frutas entonces nos podemos poner
a contar y aquí tenemos una dos tres
cuatro cinco frutas ok tenemos cinco
frutas y luego podemos contar cuántas de
todas esas cinco frutas son amarillas y
bueno pues aquí tenemos estas dos frutas
amarillas aunque por lo menos como yo
dibujé a estas frutas estas son las
únicas frutas amarillas entonces decimos
que dos quintas partes de la fruta
son amarillas amarillas y listo
bueno pero ahora vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo más para que quede muy claro
ahora digamos que tenemos una barra de
chocolate bueno ya sé que estoy haciendo
puros ejemplos de comida supongo que es
porque tengo hambre porque se acerca la
hora de la cena pero bueno supongamos
que dividimos esta barra de chocolate en
cinco pedazos iguales que tenemos 1 2 3
4 y 5 y ya sé que no me quedaron todas
exactamente del mismo tamaño pero vamos
a suponer que cada uno de estos pedazos
son iguales
y tengo hambre así es que me como este
pedazo de la barra de chocolate
y como también este otro pedazo de la
barra de chocolate estos pedazos
básicamente desaparecen y entonces qué
fracción de la barra de chocolate me
comí bueno pues la barra de chocolates
tiene cinco pedazos iguales y hay cinco
pedazos iguales en esta barra de
chocolate hay cinco secciones y me comí
dos de ellos ok me comí dos de ellos
entonces dos quintos de esta barra de
chocolate desaparecieron porque me lo
comí ok
dos quintos de la barra de chocolate me
los comí me comí bueno ya los voy a
dejar aquí tal vez haga otro vídeo
acerca de fracciones que no tenga tanta
comida involucrada pero este concepto de
las fracciones es súper útil e
importante y te invito a que pienses
mucho en esto y luego hagas los
ejercicios de la página de khan academy